SPEAKER:
In '75, '76 New York,
there was a very cool
disco culture.
SPEAKER 2: Before there was ever
a Saturday Night Fever,
Robert said,
"This is
a 100-million-dollar movie."
SPEAKER 3: Robert was the agent
for The Who, Cream,
and The Bee Gees.
-SPEAKER: He understood music
-SPEAKER 4: And could see beyond
a hit record.
SPEAKER 5: This was a chance
to build his empire.
SPEAKER: Robert is transitioning
into producing movies.
They sign John Travolta
to a three-picture deal.
But we didn't have
any pictures to support it.
SPEAKER 5: Robert was pitching
this little disco movie.
SPEAKER 2: Robert didn't know
how it would be cast,
he didn't know
what the script would be.
He just knew a fabulous story
which had global appeal
was right there.
SPEAKER 4:
And Robert saw the soundtrack
as being the killer ingredient.
The studio wasn't interested
in soundtracks.
REPORTER: The album has sold
more than ten million copies.
SPEAKER 7: Paramount never had
a piece of the album.
SPEAKER 8:
I had no idea what we had.
I didn't even know
it was a musical.
SPEAKER 9: I don't think
anybody foresaw
the phenomenon of this movie
other than Robert Stigwood
and John Travolta.
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
SPEAKER 3: One of Robert's
great achievements
is to wake up the synergy
between records and film.
(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
♪ (UPBEAT, DISCO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪